hello reject nation Greg Alba here Joe
John page sure know the day requests
from Kent McKnight one of our reward
tiers whatever video you request we must
definitely do weather reaction or
discussion of course it's a reaction
this video actually only came out a
couple months ago I legally married and
my sister's boyfriend
hello the mill is a huge youtuber all
right have not seen this video I've
never seen this person's channel but I
do know this person's famous Thank You
mo Mills and I was only allowed to post
this video under one condition most
likely to get married bless one two
three don't be fooled this is the face
of a [ __ ] idiot
let me just about 38 hours this not only
makes sense if I'd like two days on the
Lillie Joe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a wonderfully edited yeah this
is wonderful
[Music]
[Laughter]
great idea [ __ ]
[Music]
the beloved we are gathered here today
on a very special occasion day Mitchell
and L are going to become husband and
wife congratulations to you both
Thank You Mitchell you have L to be a
wife you promise to love her honor the
comfort and cherish her in sickness and
health
I did this is terrible husband
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa I've never seen this girl before
she is so [ __ ] funny yeah yeah so
freakin hilarious I love the way that's
edited yeah it's better I've seen a lot
of vlogs before and normally they're
they're pretty just linear well a
specific order you slap together a cool
montage every once in a while there's an
actual storytelling method she has to
the editing style here that I think is
great I don't know she has an editor she
does it herself there are actual shots
you know it's composed a bit it has a
rhythm yeah it's very kinetic it feels
like I'm watching an actual show but
crunched into four minutes yeah yeah
that's what's great about it it's like
this is an only video I've ever seen of
these people but I feel like I got a
good sense of even the ones we barely
spend time with you get a good sense of
who all of them pretty much are she
seems like such a funny and wacky
character I love all the
self-deprecating humor she had so
awareness of what a vlog is into it's
better just wrap this up with a cheesy
montage yeah hey man there's the beauty
of the Internet age is everything's a
little bit self-aware everything's a
little bit behind the curtain and this
is kind of magical I was sad I didn't
rehearse with the family being upset
family
totally be upset by something like that
oh yeah I can't imagine any idea I can't
imagine this sister being happy about
that at all that would be such an upset
for just a joke that would be a really
upsetting thing but I think everybody
can sort of appreciate what's going on
here it's sort of like a I feel like the
reaction was was appropriate it was like
it is kind of a it is a very silly idea
nobody seems to have any qualms about
the description box
show some love to my sister and my
husband I love how she had like a
learning lesson about it too like this
was actual storyline yeah I thought it I
thought this was brilliant man the way
this was all cut together the choice of
music and everything
great narration great script behind it
all really charming yeah I was I was
pleasantly surprised by how much I
enjoyed that now that was brilliantly
done I'm gonna check out more of this
girl's videos I don't really watch vlog
channels but this seems like the kind of
vlog Channel I could watch cuz it's not
like meandering it's not like oh just a
bunch of footage about my day with yeah
you know I get the appeal of that to
something that's a little more assembled
like this
yeah and bite-size and this video is
requested by none other than kent
McKnight Kent McKnight that's not a
knife this is a knife no I know I know I
know I am more of an AA in there oh you
use the master of the Australian accent
or a new job and trying for so many
months I'm closer than I was before no I
know if-- knife yeah I becomes a knife
knife knife see it's hard it's so hard
to get the nuances and I'm not even that
great but you know yeah there are a lot
of vowels on top well Kent thanks for
requesting this video buddy
thanks dog you have such a wide range of
requests for your reward tiers it's
crazy how you mix it up
yeah I've always thinking it's gonna be
say hardcore sci-fi pop culture thing
based off what we talked about on Google
hangout yeah never that it's a random
thing you always choose I want it's
amazing your subscriptions I know in our
last Google hangout I seem to make you a
little bit uncomfortable I tend to ask
really deep questions I feel like I'm
the Google Hangouts I've been making a
lot of people uncomfortable I don't know
why people are still pledged to our
patreon the question to the psyche of
who you are can't I want to get to
understand and know you better body hack
you and and dissect you you're like
thirty miles away from us in Australia
I'm never gonna be able to meet up with
you thirty I don't want to drive an hour
to see you I'd like to get to know you
on a more personal basis everyone I do
meet you in person I'm gonna be like I
know who you what I'm gonna kiss you on
your lips be like stick out your tongue
only suck on it
it's things like that why people aren't
comfortable in the Google hangout guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos
and check us out on patreon love y'all